Those of you who watched our Don’t buy a
MacBook Just yet video and decided to wait
to buy a MacBook, Congratulations, because
Apple has just released a couple of new MacBooks
this morning!
So in this video, we’re gonna go through
everything that’s changed with these new
MacBooks and we’ll recommend which 2019
MacBook you should buy depending on your needs.
We’ll also talk about the rumored 16”
MacBook Pro.
For starters, Apple has quietly got rid of
the $1300 12” Retina MacBook and the old
$999 MacBook Air, so their lineup is much
more simple now.
And this morning, Apple has released a new
13” MacBook Air with nothing but the addition
of some display tech and a $100 price reduction
to $1099, which is awesome news for users
who need a budget MacBook.
Apple has also finally updated the lower-end
13” MacBook Pro after two long years, bringing
it from a dual-core processor to a quad-core,
as well as bringing the Touch Bar as standard
for the same $1299 price.
Now I’ve got to call this an incredible
value.
And if you’re a student, you can pick one
of these up for $100 less and get a free pair
of Beats headphones with Apple’s back to
school sale, which we’ll link to in the
description.
The only thing that’s changed on the MacBook
Air is the addition of True Tone technology,
which adjusts the white balance of the display
to match your surroundings.
I personally love this feature since it’s
easier on the eyes when you’re in a warm-lit
room.
The new low-end MacBook Pro released this
morning gets True Tone as well, along with
a bunch of other upgrades like getting the
Touch Bar with Touch ID, and getting Apple’s
T2 chip, which is great for security, video
encoding and automatic storage encryption.
It’s now packing a new 8th gen quad-core
processor which is clocked lower than the
old dual-core, but it will definitely be a
lot faster with hyperthreading and a pretty
high turbo boost.
It’s also getting a bump up to Iris Plus
645 integrated graphics, which will perform
somewhere in between the old 640 and 655 graphics
that comes in the $1800 MacBook Pro.
We’ll be getting our hands on both of these
new MacBooks soon, so if you want to see us
test them, click subscribe right now so you
don’t miss those videos!
Neither of them are packing Apple’s rumored
new scissor keyboard, they’re still packing
the butterfly keyboard, which should be updated
with the new, more reliable materials like
we saw on the high-end 2019 MacBook Pros.
On the plus side, if you’re still worried
about the keyboard, Apple has added both new
MacBooks to their keyboard repair program,
so if you have any issues, Apple will fix
them for free.
We’re still expecting Apple to announce
the 16” MacBook Pro with the new scissor
keyboard later this year, maybe in September
or October, so if you’re looking to buy
a high-end MacBook Pro, you should probably
wait.
But for everyone else who was waiting for
an update to the lower-end MacBooks, here’s
everything that’s different between the
new MacBook Air and the new MacBook Pro.
The MacBook Air has 2 hours of extra battery
life.
The MacBook Pro will have much better processor
and graphics performance.
The Pro has a brighter 500 nit display and
a much more color accurate display than the
Air, with P3 wide-color gamut, just like the
higher-end MacBook Pros.
The Pro also has better speakers than the
Air, and it comes with Bluetooth 5.0, while
the Air sticks to 4.2.
The Air gets the Hey Siri feature while the
Pro doesn’t, but I always turn it off anyway
since I don’t really care for it.
The Air’s keyboard is also sloped downward
so you get a more comfortable typing experience,
but the Pro has a larger trackpad, which I
personally love.
The Pro gets a much faster 61W charger compared
to 30W on the Air, and of course, the Pro
is $200 more expensive, which means you can
get 256GB of storage on the Air for the same
price as the 128GB MacBook Pro.
However, the Pro is packing an incredible
value this year, and we would strongly recommend
anyone who can afford the Pro to buy it over
the Air.
In fact, the $1800 MacBook Pro is not that
much better than the new low-end model.
It just gets Hey Siri support, an extra two
Thunderbolt 3 ports, slightly faster graphics,
and faster quad-core processors, that’s
it.
How much storage you choose is up to you,
but we’d recommend at least 256GB if you
love to deal with a lot of files and do work
on your MacBook.
And now that we have a more complete lineup
of MacBooks this year, let’s begin with
our 2019 MacBook buyer’s guide.
If you just need a basic MacBook for doing
things like using the internet, using web-based
apps, doing basic school or business work,
and streaming shows and movies on the internet,
then the MacBook Air will be perfect for you.
It gets more battery life, and you’ll save
a good amount of cash.
And you’ll probably be fine with 128GB of
storage unless you really like storing photos
and files.
Now if you need a bit more performance or
you do entry-level professional work, then
the new $1299 MacBook Pro is for you.
It packs a better and brighter display which
is great for things like photo editing, and
now that it has a quad-core processor, faster
graphics performance and Apple’s T2 chip,
it can actually do basic 4K or HEVC codec
video editing.
The quad-core processor may be clocked at
a lower 1.4GHz compared to the $1800 MacBook
Pros 2.4GHz processor, but the turbo boost
speeds are almost the same, so there may not
actually be a massive difference between the
two.
And the extra processing power means you’ll
get more out of a powerful eGPU setup, which
we’ll definitely be testing soon, so make
sure to subscribe now.
Getting an eGPU means you may actually be
able to do some high-end video editing and
get a ton of extra gaming performance.
So the new low-end 13” MacBook Pro is perfect
for an eGPU setup.
So now for the $1800 MacBook Pro, who should
buy it?
Well, if you’re someone who really needs
the extra processing power, like for higher-end
photo editing, using Logic, or coding, then
you’ll gain from the higher-end 13” MacBook
Pro.
The biggest reason to upgrade to that model,
however, is for the two extra Thunderbolt
3 ports.
If you know you’ll need the extra ports,
then you should definitely get that model
instead.
And it already comes with a 256GB SSD, so
in reality, you’re actually paying just
$300 more for better performance.
And finally, we have the 15” MacBook Pro.
If you love large displays, or you want a
lot more performance, with it’s standard
6-core i7 processor, a dedicated graphics
chip, faster RAM and more of it, then you
should definitely buy the 15” MacBook Pro.
This is great for video editors who don’t
want to buy an eGPU, or anyone else who wants
some extra power for their professional work.
It also comes with better speakers, a larger
trackpad and a faster charger.
Now if you want a very high-end MacBook Pro,
like in the $3000 range, we strongly recommend
that you wait a couple of months for the 16”
MacBook Pro announcement that we’re all
expecting.
It’s gonna be expensive, but we think it’ll
feature the long-awaited full redesign of
the MacBook Pro, with a new, better keyboard
and a better display with thinner bezels.
And it seems like that redesign could carry
over into the rest of the MacBook lineup within
the next year or two, where we may see the
switch to Apple’s new ARM processors.
So there you have it guys, if this video helped
you make a buying decision, hit that like
button and click the circle above to subscribe
so you don’t miss out when we get these
new MacBooks in our office.
Thanks for watching, and we’ll see you in
the next video.